Guten Morgen, Linus.
Logbuch Netzpolitik vom 30. Oktober 2018, live aus der Metaebene hier in Berlin. Ich bin wie immer zu Gast bei Tim.
Hallo Linus, ich freu mich so. Wir haben uns so lange nicht gesehen. Erst in Wien kürzlich.
Tim, wir hatten Feedback auf die letzte Sendung und zwar harshes Feedback.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Hat sich ein gewisser Herr Neumann gemeldet bei mir und schrieb, habe ich das richtig mitbekommen, dass ihr die AfD-Plattform zur Meldung von Lehrern, die von der Wahl der AfD abraten, nicht als üblen Einstieg in Denunziation und Hetze wahrnehmen wollt?
Ich verstehe nicht, wie ihr darauf kommt.
Bin ich interessiert. Findest du in Ordnung so eine Plattform?
Wir haben uns klar dazu geäußert im letzten Podcast. Das ist ja wohl eine Dreistigkeit, eine Unterstellung.
Ja, ich habe überlegt, ob wir nicht vielleicht ein bisschen zu vorsichtig mit dem, also zu wenig gesagt haben, dass das natürlich absoluter Scheiß ist.
Also mehr am Anfang einsortieren meinst du?
Mehr vorher sagen hier, dass sowas ist Scheiß. Das muss man offenbar heute noch mal den Leuten erklären. Und ich finde es wahrscheinlich auch interessant, dass man es tatsächlich heute klarer sagen muss. Vielleicht ist es auch wichtig, einfach sowas immer weiter zu betonen. Denn wir haben halt irgendwie ein paar Jahrzehnte Politik in diesem Land hinter uns, wo Parteien sowas nicht gemacht haben.
Ja, das und wir haben jetzt ja zu sagen, die letzte mit der Hessen-Wahl im letzten Parlament nun auch noch die AfD. Vielleicht muss man sich stärker positionieren. Vielleicht stimmt das. Wir nehmen uns das vor, oder Linus?
Wir nehmen uns das vor und betonen natürlich, dass diese Aktion einfach mal totaler Scheiß ist. Und das ist auch eine, und zwar unabhängig davon, von wem so etwas kommt, sind solche Denunziationsplattformen und so wirklich, wirklich eine ziemlich beschissen Idee, die aber hier glaube ich auch sehr gezielt von der AfD verwendet wurde, um die kontroverse Debatte darüber zu bekommen.
Also begrüßen wir eigentlich den etwas zu hauschen Kommentar, indem wir das als Positionierung neu nutzen konnten.
Genau, dann zu der LNP 272, wo der Frank zu Gast war.
Welcher Frank?
Frank Rieger, der hat auch so ein Buch geschrieben, mit der Constanze zusammen.
Ja, mit der habe ich neulich geredet.
Genau, wir haben mit Frank über das Buch von Constanze und Frank gesprochen und über die Bayernwahl.
Ja, und die Geschichte der Bayernwahl war ja sehr interessant.
Die Geschichte der Bayernwahl im Wandel. Und ich habe gesagt, die CSU habe 10% verloren. Das ist natürlich falsch.
Ja, habe ich gelesen in den Kommentaren. Man muss da genauer sein.
Es ist falsch, natürlich. Wenn du mit der Tesla-Aktie denkst, du hättest 10% verloren oder 10% gewonnen, das ist unterschiedlich, denn es geht hier natürlich um Prozentpunkte. Und so bittet Henning um etwas mehr mathematisch-sprachliche Genauigkeit bei der Besprechung von Wahlergebnissen. Die Veränderungen der Prozentwerte der Parteien im Vergleich zur letzten Wahl sind bitte in Prozentpunkten vom Gesamtergebnis anzugeben und nicht als Prozent, was sich bei Nichtnennung der Bezugsbasis eher auf die Anzahl der Wederstimmen der Partei beziehen würde. Wenn eine Partei also von 50% bei der letzten auf 40% bei dieser Wahl absackt. Angenommen, die Wahlbeteiligung liegt bei beiden Wahlen gleich hoch, hat die Partei aber 20% ihrer Wählerinnen verloren.
Wir können uns da nicht rauswieseln, Linus. Wir haben einen Fehler gemacht, aber ich habe mir die Passage nochmal angehört. Das ist schon eher du.
War ich, ja, habe ich falsch gesagt. Könnte er hinschreiben, Neumann falsch.
Dann sieht man aber auch die Aufmerksamkeit der Zuhörer. Ich finde das auch okay, den Kommentar.
Ich finde das super. Gerade, wenn genau darauf geachtet wird. Hier, das wäre, 20% klingt ja viel mehr. Hätte man von vornherein, hätte ich ja schöner sagen können.
Oder in ganzer Zahl.
Kann man aber auch jetzt in den Diskussionen mit der SPD und der CDU in Hessen auch nochmal anbringen. Ich glaube, den Fehler machen viele. Nur, um mich da ein bisschen zu relativieren.
Ich glaube, Statistik-Nords haben bei Wahlen echt kurze Nächte, weil sie immer an Tischkanten beißen müssen.
Ich bin da völlig dabei. Ich würde mich auch die ganze Zeit darüber ärgern. Ich habe mich lange genug mit Statistik auseinandergesetzt. Den Punkt nehme ich zur Kenntnis.
Haben wir noch mehr Kommentare, die wir besprechen sollten, Linus?
Nein, ich glaube, Tim, wir haben eigentlich nur noch so ein bisschen vielleicht Kommentare zu dem Buch von Konstanze und Franke.
Ich habe ein bisschen Kritik gelesen.
Aha, was gibt es für Kritik?
Also jetzt in den Kommentaren zum Podcast. Da ging es ein bisschen auch um die Verlinkung zu Amazon vor allen Dingen.
Ja, Tim, das ist aber dein Problem von dir.
Ich habe aber auch geantwortet und ein bisschen erklärt, wie ich das in der Metaebene so mache. Und ich hoffe, meine schriftlichen Ausführungen waren dafür ausreichend. Ich habe mich länger in den Kommentaren geäußert dazu.
Das ist richtig. Es gibt da einen Kommentar, der es eben nicht in Ordnung findet, dass da Amazon verlinkt wird, weil es politisch bessere Bucherläden an anderen Straßenrändern gibt, wenn die uns ein schönes Affiliate-Programm anbieten, verlinken wir auch die.
Also wir waren da ja jetzt nur ehrlich.
Der Kritikpunkt ist natürlich auch valide. Einzige, wo ich nicht mit einhergehen würde, ist, dann direkt zu sagen, die Meta-Ebene sei aber jetzt halt werbefinanziert, denn das, was der Frank uns gezahlt hat, dafür, dass wir ihn hier mal in die Sendung gelassen haben, das war wirklich wenig.
Also wir kennen ja die Summe, aber die werden wir hier natürlich auch nicht offenlegen. In unserer neuen Transparenz-Initiative.
Aber mein neues iPhone XS hast du schon gesehen, ne?
Den Podcast kann man aber sehr, sehr empfehlen, wollte ich nur noch mal sagen.
Der war gut.
Eher total.
Das Buch übrigens auch. Wir machen direkt noch mal einen Amazon-Link in die Show Notes. Aber gibt es denn auch Kritik an dem Buch? Ich habe gesehen, netzpolitik.org hat jetzt gerade einen Ausschnitt, oder wie nennt man das?
Ein Auszug.
Ein Auszug mal abgedruckt. Cyberwar, der endlose Krieg. Den Link findet ihr in den Show Notes. Geht nicht über Amazon.
Also ein Kapitel, aber ein gekürztes Kapitel aus dem Buch. Es gibt ja immer so Vorabdrucker, aber man kann natürlich auch nachher, wenn man den Verlag fragt, Teile des Buches abdrucken, wenn man möchte. Und in dem Stück geht es so ein bisschen um, vor allen Dingen, dass so eine Art von digitaler Krieg nicht endet, warum der endlos ist. Und dann geht es auch so ein bisschen um ein paar konkrete Beispiele, die wir da haben von der NSA. Also Gebietsstreitigkeiten im Digitalen. Also lohnt sich durchaus zu lesen, wenn man sich so ein bisschen für die strategischen Fragen in diesen Cyber-Konflikten interessiert.
Diese strategischen Spielchen sind ja tatsächlich sowieso so ein bisschen die reizvollste Auseinandersetzung, die man so haben kann. Frank neigt da ja auch sehr stark zu, sich da auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich glaube, also Constanze und Frank haben, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen den historischen Blick auch ein Interesse. Also zum einen immer das Vergleichen mit dem Kalten Krieg, aber auch so generell, wie sich Militärstrategien ändern. Aber ich muss sagen, die Kommentare zu dem Buch sind natürlich jetzt, die waren eher aktueller. Also zum einen, weil diese China-Geschichte gab, mit dem zu sagen chinesischen Ship bei Bloomberg, aber auch weil noch der Lagebericht kam von BSI. Das war ja auch so ein bisschen, dass man einfach einen aktuellen Swing kriegt. Und dann hat was verändert, also die FAZ oder die Frankfurter Allgemeine Sonntagszeitung, die hatte einen Vorabdruck zu einem speziellen Kapitel, nämlich dem zur Desinformation. Und dann gab es natürlich auch relativ viel Feedback dazu. Also jetzt hat mir Constanze erzählt.
Desinformation, das ist ja irgendwie das Bleib, irgendwie das Thema, was alle beschäftigt.
Wird es ja auch. Also ich bin schon gespannt, wie das jetzt wird zur Europawahl. Da wird sicherlich auch noch mal eine Debatte aufkommen. Mal gucken, die Midtermwahlen in den USA, das ist ja jetzt auch nur noch ein paar Tage. Das wird schon nochmal interessant.
Beto Oberg, Texas, wieder in demokratischer Hand.
Ich finde es ja interessant, dass sie diese ganzen Fragen von Beeinflussung der öffentlichen Meinung offenbar wichtiger finden als ihr Wahlcomputerproblem. Das finde ich ja nach wie vor beeindruckend.
Das ist echt amüsant, ne? Das ist wirklich amüsant.
Also auch jetzt übrigens in Brasilien. Also wir haben jetzt auch die Brasilienwahl mit diesem ziemlich krassen Rechtspopulisten da.
Neoliberale, das ist der neoliberale Liebling der Märkte.
Neoliberale, das ist ein echter Rechts.
Hat die Deutsche Bank heute getwittert. Echt? Der neoliberale Liebling der Märkte.
Der Typ ist im Waffenhaut ein bisschen irre. Also, aber gut. Ich hätte seinen Widersacher ja auch nicht erwähnt. Der Typ ist sozusagen Teil des Korruptionsskandals. Aber der Punkt ist, dass die in keiner Weise nachsehen können. Das ist ein komplett elektronisches System. In Brasilien auch schon seit langem. Eine reine elektronische Urme, wie sie das nennen.
Ich bin kürzlich auch wieder genötigt worden, das noch einmal zu erklären. Und auf der Privacy Week trat dieser David Schaum auf, der dann auch irgendwie groß davon erzählte, der hat ein neues System am Start, wie er die Welt jetzt mit Electronic Voting in der Blockchain besser macht.
Aber er hat auch Widerworte gekriegt. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass da alle genickt haben.
Der hat sich ja größtenteils selber Widerworte gegeben. Der hatte etwas Schwierigkeiten, da seine Gedanken zu sortieren. Aber es ist erstaunlich, dass selbst Leute, die jetzt irgendwie Fundus an Problemen zur Auswahl haben, um die sie sich kümmern könnten, ausgerechnet das nehmen, wo es am wenigsten eins ist und das größte Potenzial besteht, ein größeres zu schaffen.
Und David Schaum ist ja nun niemand, dem man verdächtigen würde, dass er es technisch nicht verstündende. Also er hat ja ein hohes Verständnis auch von der Komplexität von z.B. kryptographischen Anwendungen. Aber der Punkt, den das Urteil hier in Deutschland gemacht hat, zu sagen, ohne eine nähere Sachkenntnis sollte man es verstehen können, der wird so derart übergangen, als wenn das keine Rolle spielt.
Und das ist genau der entscheidende Punkt, weil du hast ja heute schon eine Zeit, in der die Leute nicht mehr wissen, wem sie glauben wollen. Und wenn du jetzt auf einmal nur noch wenige Experten hast, die sagen können, hier, da wurde manipuliert, im Prinzip dann noch zu sagen, okay, gibt jetzt irgendwie eine Anzahl von Experten, die das herausfinden können, die mag jetzt sogar vielleicht noch weltweit absolut relativ groß sein, dann stellt sich aber die Frage, wie muss deren jeweiliger Ruf sein, damit denen noch jemand glaubt? Vor allem dann in einem Land, wo der Präsident irgendwie so sagt, ungefähr so 30.000 Leute wollte ich eh erstmal hier beim nächsten Reinigungssonntag mal irgendwie loswerden. Dann wird das echt schwierig.
Ich meine, Linus, wir sind uns da eh eigentlich nicht lange. Aber für mich sind es im Wesentlichen zwei Punkte. Der erste ist, ich glaube, dass wir ganz konsequent verhindern müssen, dass Wahlen ein Markt werden. Das ist, was letztlich dahinter steht. Und der zweite ist, dass alle diese Anbieter nur von dem Vertrauen aus Papierwahlverfahren profitieren. Das Vertrauen, das Leute jetzt haben. Und es geht ja immer darum, den Verlierer zu überzeugen. Und die zwei Punkte hat mir noch nie einer ordentlich widerlegen können. Aber Linus, wir waren uns da schon lange einig seit über zehn Jahren.
Ja, wir hoffen nur, dass wir mehr Leute davon überzeugt bekommen.
Ich bin nicht sicher. Mittlerweile, vielleicht sollten wir es auch nutzen. Also ich mein, komm, wir müssen schon noch Hacker genug für.
Wir könnten echt sagen, okay, komm, wir machen hier ein Wahlsystem.
Ja, PC-Wahl, Alter.
Kommt raus, kommt raus, ich bin Kanzler.
Ihr hättet es dir mal anders überlegen können.
Ja, das wär's gewesen. Da hätte man die Demokratie noch retten können.
Ja, wir haben auch eine ordentliche Hackerethik.
Eine sanfte Überführung in den Linusismus. Und dann vorsichtig die Netze in Nutzerhand, sanfte Enteignung an den entschieden Stellen. Das hätten die zu spät gemerkt. Wahlen und Computer. Bleiben wir aber noch mal ganz kurz bei Cyber und Desinformation. Die Bloomberg-Story, das ist ja auch mal wieder so ein irgendwie schönes Ding. Also die wurden jetzt von Tim Cook ja noch mal aufgefordert. Nehmt die Story zurück, das ist alles irgendwie Unfug, was ihr hier behauptet. Leute, die sich überhaupt nicht mit Aktien auseinandersetzen, sagen auch so, so billig kriegst du Supermicro nie wieder.
Also Supermicro ist sozusagen die betroffene Firma.
Die Firma, deren Aktienkurs um 50 Prozent runtergegangen ist.
Nicht Prozentpunkte. Zwei Erleifern, die ich jetzt ein bisschen nachher betrachtet darin interessiert, einer ist, wie intensiv sich diese, besonders die amerikanische Tech-Szene mit dem Inhalt dieses Artikel auseinandergesetzt hat. Und auch mit den sehr genauen Dementis, vor allen Dingen von Apple, die waren ja relativ schnell dabei. Und wie sachlich eigentlich die Debatte darüber war. Dann kam das Nachlegen von Bloomberg, wo wieder eine Menge, also dort konnte die Tech-Community nicht überzeugen. Aber letztlich, sie sind ja auch nicht zurückgerudert. Das fand ich eher überraschend.
Was nun? Irgendjemand muss jetzt mal ziehen. Oder Bloomberg bleibt einfach jetzt...
Nee, sie hätten es belegen müssen. Auch können. Ich glaube, Bloomberg ist am Ende auf der Loser-Seite. Okay, dann wollen wir uns mal wieder ein.
Aber warum haben die sich jemals überhaupt mit dieser Story in diese... Also, haben die gedacht, die kommen damit durch?
Na ja, kommt auf das Ziel an, nicht wahr? Also, da ist jetzt schon ein Schaden entstanden, ganz klar. Und also, die böswillige Auslegung wäre ja, sie haben sich Informationen durchstechen lassen. Offensichtlich von Geheimdienstlern. Die hatten vielleicht Ziele. Die bisschen freundliche Interpretation ist ja, sie haben sozusagen Dinge vermischt, die nicht zusammengehören. Sie haben technisch Dinge nicht verstanden. Vielleicht liegt es auch irgendwo dazwischen.
Oder die hatten super micro-geschortet.
Und jemand freut sich jetzt ja ganz viel. Aber ich denke, entweder legen die da nochmal nach oder müssten sie sich am Ende korrigieren.
Dafür wäre es jetzt zu spät.
Eigentlich schon, finde ich auch. Die Zeit ist jetzt schon.
Hätten sie früher machen müssen, wird nichts mehr kommen?
Also vor allen Dingen, das ist ja kein luftleerer Raum. Du kannst das ja technisch hernehmen und analysieren. Das sind ja auch physische Geräte. Was haben die gedacht? Ich denke, da sitzen jetzt auch welche dran. Das ist meine Hoffnung.
Das Problem ist ja dann wieder, jeder, der jetzt so ein super Microbot rausholt und sagt, da ist kein Chip, dann kann Bloomberg sagen, siehste, da ist keiner. Ich denke, die werden langfristig ihren Schaden in Berichterstattung über diese Themen jetzt haben. Das können sie jetzt einstellen.
Man sieht ein bisschen die Macht, die in diesen Behauptungen steckt. Und auch so ein bisschen diese, man muss die Quellen nicht benennen, sondern man kann, wenn man nur mehrere davon hat, daraus eine Story bauen. Also ich finde, eigentlich ist es ein bisschen prototypisch, wenn man so an Journalistenschulen was lehren will über Berichterstattung und über die Macht von Geheimdiensten.
Aber interessanterweise, also gerade in diesem IT-Security-Bereich ist Berichterstattung sehr häufig genau diesen Limitationen. Also ähnlichen. Erstens, es ist für die Berichtenden, Journalistinnen und Journalisten, teilweise nicht möglich, das vollständig zu verstehen.
Gibt nicht so viele, die wirklich viel Ahnung haben, aber es gibt mittlerweile welche.
Es gibt welche, klar, aber so oder so kommt erschwerend hinzu, das hat nämlich noch nicht mal nur mit ihrer eigenen Kompetenz zu tun, sondern auch, wenn das betroffene Unternehmen im Rahmen von Mitigationsmaßnahmen irgendwas unternimmt. Das heißt, zum Zeitpunkt Null entdeckt jemand eine Schwachstelle, meldet die an das Unternehmen und ab dem Moment hast du ja dann ein Moving Target. Das hatten wir damals bei PC Wahl sehr schön gesehen, wo wir jeden Tag neu das Ding aufmachen mussten, weil die immer wieder schlechte Mitigationen ausgerollt haben. Dann war immer der Stand für die berichterstattenden Personen, insbesondere in dem Fall Kai Biermann, der sagt, die haben gesagt, sie hätten das jetzt behoben. Und zwar, dann mussten wir halt gucken, sagen sie nein, haben sie, ja sie haben das behoben, sie haben das durch ein neues, größeres Problem ersetzt. Und da ist jetzt schon klar, der Journalist hätte jetzt in dem Fall noch so kompetent sein können. Dadurch, dass du ein moving target hast, stehen dann halt Aussage gegen Aussage. Und das ging aber immer gut.
Ne, das war eine Vertrauensfrage. Der Journalist hat sozusagen mit dem Tim auch eine Vertrauensbasis. Also wenn der weiß, okay, die gucken da jetzt rein und die sagen mir einen halben Tag oder Tag später das Ergebnis, dann lügen die mich nicht voll. Aber ihr seid nun okay eine Truppe von Geheimdienstlern oder Contractors oder so. Also ihr habt einfach andere, ihr habt auch ein Wahrheitsinteresse, was ihr teilt mit dem Journalisten. Und da ist natürlich jetzt nicht klar, ob dem Bloomberg Journalisten, also was die Motive dahinter waren.
Warum ich das anspreche ist, weil ja gerade unsere Freunde Thorsten und Martin wieder in so einer Situation sind. Die haben eine Gesundheits-App aufgemacht, die vollmundig angetreten ist. Ja, hier, speichert doch einfach alle eure Gesundheitsdaten hier. Das ist eine gute Sache, ist Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt. Und Martin hat das mehr oder weniger in der Mittagspause da reingeschaut, hat eine ganze Reihe an Schwachstellen gefunden. Und dann war die Frage eben, okay, wie geht man damit um? Na ja, wie immer, melden, Deadline setzen, Veröffentlichungen anstreben. Und das betroffene Unternehmen hat irgendwie die Schwachstellen dankend in Empfang genommen, um Verlängerung der Deadline gebeten.
Aber die sind auch okay, das machen noch relativ viele.
Völlig in Ordnung, das handelt man ja dann irgendwie aus und sagt, okay, dann eben eine Woche später oder so. Und kommt jetzt irgendwie mehr oder weniger mit einer Kommunikationsstrategie um die Ecke, in der sie sagen, es waren alles gar keine Schwachstellen und es bestand zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung. Und es ist total unrealistisch. Genau, es ist unrealistisch. Und jetzt denkst du dir halt so, sorry, dafür macht man jetzt das Responsibles Closure nicht.
Erstens ist es eine Dreistigkeit vor dem Herrn, weil da hat jemand für lau quasi eine Sicherheitsprüfung übernommen. Da hat jemand eklatante, handwerkliche Mängel aufgedeckt, die übrigens der Klassiker sind. Wenn ich noch mal an das Buch von Frank- und Franz-Hans-Hanns-Zweidnern darf, das ist ja ein strukturales Problem. Die haben offenbar von bestimmten Dingen keine Ahnung. Aber gut. Und dann sozusagen sich auch noch hinzustellen und argumentativ umdrehen zu wollen, ist eine einzige Frechheit.
Und das war bei PC-Wahl genauso? Ja, die waren noch inkompetenter. Okay, die waren noch inkompetenter, aber die haben auch –ich habe das ja im Vortrag auch nochmal wiederholt –Tagesschau-Meldungen an dem Tag, an denen der Hersteller nachgebessert hat. Und du denkst dir so, das ist einfach nicht der Fall. Übrigens habe ich jetzt gerade in der Berichterstattung zu der Hessen-Wahl noch mal gelesen, dass die auch nie wieder nachgebessert haben. Für das Projekt PC-Wahl gibt es keine Updates mehr. Und in Hessen, die haben noch mal damit die Wahl durchgeführt. Die haben damals, was ja auch immer unser Vorwurf war, die Update-Funktion sogar ausgeschaltet. Mit anderen Worten, dann konnten die Leute auch nicht mehr updaten. Und es gibt jetzt auch keine Updates mehr. Das war ein kurzer Exkurs eben diese PC-Wahl-Sache. Aber interessanterweise, da stand ja jetzt das Team von ID aktuell eben auch vor dem Punkt, dass wir an einem Tag released hatten. Die behauptet haben ja, okay, das haben wir alles behoben. So, jetzt konnte es natürlich innerhalb eines Tages, konnte, was weiß ich, wer das damals berichtet hat, Ingo Zamparoni oder so, dann auch nicht sagen, ey, okay, ich lad mir mal kurz hier die Demo-Exploits runter und gucke mal, ob die noch alle funktionieren, was sie zu dem Zeitpunkt natürlich taten. Vivi, gleich, also ähnlich gelagerter Fall, kommt in diese Kommunikation, kriegt das alles freihaus und die haben einen wirklich vielen Seiten Bericht. Und was machen die mit dem Bericht? Neben dieses gesamte Gerüst-Templett, das Gerüst dieses Berichts, das Berichtsgerüst-Templett, und schreiben dann irgendwie so, ja hier hin und hier und hier und da und da und da. Also das ist halt auch irgendwie kein, das ist einfach nicht der Umgang, den ich von jemandem erwarte, der möchte, dass ich meine Gesundheitsdaten in diese Äppler reinlade.
Glauben die echt, dass jemand noch mal auf der Kundenseite, der möglicherweise ein potenzieller Kunde ist, denen noch mal vertraut?
Und das ist halt das Problem, dass ich glaube tatsächlich, dass die eine realistische Wahrscheinlichkeit sehen mit der Nummer durchzukommen. Weil, wenn dieser Text, in dem sie ja sagen, das ist alles irgendwie hier unrealistisch und unwahrscheinlich und geht alles gar nicht und theoretisch und dann irgendwie solche Tricks machen, wie war die Argumentation ungefähr so? Es konnte ja nie ein ganzer Datensatz extrahiert werden, sondern nur Fragmente. Und mit Fragmenten meinen die halt Dokumente. Und mehrere Dokumente sind erst ein Datensatz. Und da du pro Request nur ein Dokument daraus kriegst, kannst du halt nur ein Fragment. Wenn du mit solchen Tricks kommst, und es geht hier um deine Gesundheitsdaten, deine Krankschreibung, deine Diagnose, Röntgenbilder und Ultraschallbilder und was nicht alles, die sagen, sollst du da reinladen. Und dann haben die nicht die Position zu sagen, wie ist das eigentlich, was man bei so einer Responsibility-Scoreja macht. Ja, danke, krasses Ding, haben wir alles behoben, wir danken und so weiter. Und dann irgendwie noch so einen Gegenangriff zu starten zu einem Unternehmen, was, oder zum Forscher-Team, was in diesem Fall halt sehr freundlich war. Das führt, glaube ich, zu zwei Sachen. Also einmal dazu, dass so Nebelbomben werfen, das funktioniert halt immer.
Und bleibt was hängen, ja.
Es bleibt was hängen, so. Und das führt auch dummerweise, liebe Freunde bei Vivi, dazu, dass ihr beim nächsten Mal keine Responsible Disclosure mehr bekommt.
Ja, aber auch größer ist nicht nur die Firma. Auch bei anderen Firmen überlegt man da nochmal neu, ob man eigentlich sich noch mal reinzieht.
Ja, ob man sich das noch antut, oder ob man einfach auf Full Disclosure...
Du hast mal für Jugend hackt, weißt du das noch? Also sozusagen für Kinder und Jugendliche immer aufgeschrieben. Kannst ja nochmal verlinken, warum man das eigentlich macht. Du hast es sehr schön begründet. Was ich daran so toll fand war, dass das eigentlich jedes Kind verstehen kann.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber offenbar ist es bei vielen von den betroffenen Firmen wie so eine Abwehrreaktion, die auch nicht logisch ist.
Eine Reaktion, die man zum Beispiel sehr, sehr häufig hat, ohne jetzt zu behaupten, dass das in diesem konkreten Fall so gewesen wäre, denn woher sollte ich das nun wissen, ist, dass Unternehmen sich sehr bemühen, dass es nicht zu einer Veröffentlichung kommt. Das ist sehr, sehr häufig so. Das versuchen die dann mit Geld.
Oder Drohungen manchmal.
Drohungen natürlich. Da kommt einfach einmal alles. Mitleid. Wir sind aber ein ganz neues Unternehmen. Wenn das jetzt, dann sind wir ja erledigt. Ja, sorry, ich hätte euren Job ordentlich machen müssen.
Naja, so diese typische, das ist unser erstes Mal. Wir sind noch unerfahren.
Dann werden so irgendwelche Angebote gemacht in Richtung, naja, wir können das ja, also die Sicherheitslücken sind uns ja auch was wert. Da können wir ja einen Bug Bounty für bezahlen. Und dann bleibt es unter uns. Und das ist aber quasi Schweigegeld. Und da ist man natürlich auch immer in einer sehr schwierigen, ich rate immer absolut davon ab, sich auf sowas einzulassen. Genau, weil die nämlich, weil das, also wir haben, habe ich ja auch glaube ich hier schon öfter erzählt, diesen Fall vor allem niemals sowieso etwas fordern. Weil wenn du das forderst, dann hast du ruckzuck die Anwälte da, die sagen, ach, wollen sie uns etwa erpressen mit ihrer Veröffentlichung von Schwarzstellen auf unser System. Oh, da kann ich mir aber echt vorstellen, dass die Richterin das irgendwie spannend findet. Und also das Spiel muss klar unter den Regeln erfolgen, die das Forscher-Team definiert bei der Abgabe. Und in dem Moment, wo ich eine Leistung kostenlos übergeben habe, nämlich ein irgendwie zweistelliger Anzahl Seiten von Bericht mit Schwarzstellen.
Also auch erklärender Bericht, also das ist ja auch eine Leistung, um das zu erklären.
Also diese Berichte, normalerweise musst du die bezahlen. Und die sind nicht billig. Und wenn du den kostenlos bekommst, dann hilft das auch nicht nachher zu bezahlen, sondern hilft das nur zu sagen, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass hier engagierte Menschen kostenlos sich bemüht haben, unsere Fehler zu korrigieren. Interessanterweise, dieses Vivi wirbt ja damit, wenn man sich diese Webseite anschaut, wie viele Unternehmen da vorher schon drauf geschaut hätten und nichts gefunden haben. Das ist ja dann auch immer sehr interessant. Diese Zertifizierungen. Wir sind aber zertifiziert hier von...
Nein, nein, keine Namen, keine Namen.
Genau, wir nennen einfach keine Namen. Es sind eben Unternehmen, die dann teilweise auch gar nichts dafür können, da genannt zu werden, weil die nämlich einen bestimmten Scope kriegen. Dann wird gesagt, prüfet bitte, wie hier unsere, was weiß ich, prüft unser Backup-System auf Brandschutz, um das jetzt zu vergleichen. Und dann kriegt man einen bestimmten Scope benannt. Und dann geht man da hin und prüft den.
Oder kriegt einen Schreibtisch-Test, das kann ja auch sein.
Genau, aber du hast quasi, du kriegst natürlich, dir wird gesagt, prüfe Folgendes, mach darüber ein Angebot. Dann sagst du, okay, dauert es so und so viele Tage, dann machst du das. Das ist genau der Grund, warum ich immer darauf achte, dass ich sowas niemals mache. Wir sagen, wir wollen eine Zertifizierung, wir wollen ein Audit. Dann zahlen wir auch das Doppelte. Ja, genau, verstehe ich schon, weil am Ende mein guter Name im Feuer steht, weil dann darunter steht, hier von dem oder dem geprüft.
Und zertifiziert natürlich.
Zertifiziert. Und dann, nachher fragt nämlich keiner mehr, dass du in Wirklichkeit nur, was weiß ich, für so und so viele Tage mit dem und dem Ziel einen Teil des Produktes geprüft hast. Und dann musst du dich nachher in so einem Fall, wenn du jetzt irgendwie die Schwarzstellen aufdeckst, musst du natürlich auch immer darauf achten, dass die dir einerseits den Credit geben. Ja, hier, diese Schwarzstellen wurden gefunden. Von dieser und jener Person. Und nicht irgendwie so jetzt noch besser, nachdem es auch noch von ModZero oder von wem auch immer irgendwie zertifiziert wurde.
Und hat eine Zeitkomponente. Also, die Zertifizierung ist von einem Zeitpunkt. Und zumindest ein Teil der Lücken kann danach entstanden sein. Das ist ja immer noch so ein...
Stimmt, genau, dann stehst du als Nächstes da.
Auf die alte Leid sozusagen.
Altes Leid, ärgerlich. Man kann sich wünschen, dass einfach... Also, wenn ihr als betroffene Unternehmen jemals so eine E-Mail kriegt.
Lass uns mal einen einladen. Wir lassen uns doch mal einen einladen, hier in den Podcast und die mal fragen. Also, ich hab mich schon oft gefragt, warum reagieren die so irrational? Und warum... Also, ich kann mich da schlechteren hineinversetzen, aber mal so.
Naja, die haben primär... Angst. Also, Angst. Insbesondere, weil du ja da auch mit den Leuten sprichst, die dafür verantwortlich sind. Nicht, weil die den Fehler gemacht haben, oder im Fall von Vivi die ganzen, diesen Tannenbaum an Fehlern, sondern weil sie die Verantwortung für dieses Team tragen, für dieses Unternehmen. Und dann ist natürlich klar, erkenn ich auch durchaus an, dieses Vivi-Ding wird jetzt noch nicht so viele Nutzerinnen haben. Da ist natürlich schlechte Presse zu Beginn nicht gut.
Ja, der Zeitpunkt ist besonders kritisch für die.
Ja, also, Entschuldigung, der Zeitpunkt ist auch besonders kritisch für alle Leute, die ihre Daten da jetzt reingeladen haben.
Aus Sicht des Responsible Disclosure, jetzt oder nie. Also ich meine, das ist sehr viel besser, als wenn die Millionen Kunden hätten.
Richtig. Das ist auch immer so, also ein Satz, den du sehr gerne hörst, ist so, das kommt jetzt aber ungelegen.
Nenn mir mann gelegenen Zeitpunkt nicht.
Wann kommt der mann gelegenen Zeitpunkt? Und dann, oh jetzt ist aber hier das, was ich... Hast du 1000 Beispiele, warum das jetzt gerade ungelegen kommt und nächste Woche besser ist? Ja nein, das...
Glaubst du, das wird sich jemals ändern? Also ich meine, wir haben jetzt schon so viele Beispiele, also auch in der Geschichte. Glaubst du, das wird sich irgendwann mal ändern?
Also ich hoffe, ich mache mir primär darüber Sorgen. Es gibt zwei Entwicklungen, die mir da Probleme bereiten. Erstens, diese Art von Schwachstellen finden und so weiter, das findet am laufenden Band statt. Wir haben jetzt hier einmal dieses Beispiel genommen, weil es deutsche Gesundheitsdaten sind, die nebenbei noch von jemandem aufgemacht wurden, den wir kennen. Aber im Prinzip, wenn du dir die CVE-Listen anschaust, das geht ja in einem durch. Quasi das offizielle Logbuch der Schwachstellen. Und die, die da gemeldet wurden.
Du kannst aber auch die Zeitung aufklappen, oder?
Genau, und jetzt, wenn du irgendwie Heise aufklappst, Jürgen Schmidt, der Security-Chefredakteur bei Heise, ist ein viel beschäftigter junger Mann. Der muss viel schreiben. Und das ist das eine, was mir Sorgen macht, diese Flut. Und zweitens, dass ich jetzt eben diese immer im zunehmenden Maße, diese Kommunikationsstrategie, gehen Sie bitte weg, hier gibt es nichts zu sehen, oder der Hersteller hat schon nachgebessert, dass das früher irgendwie man den Eindruck hatte, dass die Unternehmen das auch als Ehre für sich selber begriffen haben, dass das dann auch der Fall war. Und jetzt eben in zunehmendem Maße ist unklar, ob das überhaupt der Fall ist.
Ich würde vielleicht noch ein Drittel dazu nehmen. Meine Sorge ist auch so ein bisschen, dass diese Kultur des Responsible Disclosure damit Risse kriegt und die nimmt sowieso ab, aus ökonomischen Gründen, also aus anderen Gründen. Aber dass sie sich damit immer mehr, noch mehr überlegen, was auch nochmal mit den juristischen Drohungen, nicht nur mit der Pressearbeit zu tun hat, das wäre noch ein dritter Aspekt, den ich dazunehmen würde. Aber die beiden sägen natürlich auch. Also ist die Antwort auf meine Frage eigentlich nein? Du glaubst eher nicht, dass es besser wird?
Ich hab, also was du gerade noch mit dem Ökonomischen genannt hast, es gibt eine, finde ich, sehr löbliche Entwicklung hin zu diesem Bug Bounty Programm.
Ja doch, Frank und Franz Hönser haben mir den Buch darüber ein bisschen geschrieben. Das ist ja eigentlich eine relativ neue Entwicklung vergleichsweise mit einer Geschichte, sozusagen der Schwachstellenmeldung.
Es gibt ja jetzt diese Unternehmen primär, da gibt es zwei, HackerOne und Buckrout. Die beiden sind so, glaube ich, gibt vielleicht noch welche, die das im Prinzip anbieten as a service. Die gehen zu den Unternehmen hin und sagen hier, ihr könnt euch bei uns anmelden, was ihr quasi anbietet und was ihr bereit seid zu zahlen für welche Form von Schwachstellen. Und dann gibt es quasi so richtig freiberufliche Pentester, die auch tatsächlich dann sich da eben verdingen.
Deren Einkommen, aber es gibt natürlich immer noch die beiden Konkurrenten. Das eine ist so was wie Serodium, also dieser Markt, die Zwischenhändler denkst du jetzt mal, und natürlich Unternehmen selbst, die in sehr viel mehr Branchen als früher, also nicht nur in der IT-Branche, sondern auch in zu sagen, jetzt erstmal IT-Fernen-Branchen selber Bug Bounties anbieten. Das hat sich ja auch viel fächert. Auf eine interessante Weise. Hacker One ist interessant wegen der ganzen Nähe zu den Geheimdiensten und zum Pentagon und wie die sich aufstellen. Aber auf jeden Fall ist es damit ein ökonomisches Feld. Und das macht mir natürlich auf einer anderen Ebene Sorgen. In den USA war schon immer diese Responsible Disclosure anders debattiert als bei uns. Länger und früher debattiert aber anders. Also die europäische Hacker-Szene ist ja durchaus ein bisschen offener für Responsible Disclosure. Aber die verschiedenen Angebote, die heute faktisch gemacht werden, die sich mit verschiedenen Risiken oder auch nicht verbinden, die machen glaube ich diese Mindset kaputt. Das kann was Gutes sein, was Schlechtes. Das kann man jetzt so und so sehen.
Dieses Mindset muss man auch einfach mal hier an dieser Stelle nochmal würdigen. Da findet jemand Schwachstellen und sagt, diese Schwachstellen betreffen hier Menschen. Kritischste Daten von diesen Menschen, Gesundheitsdaten. Ich muss jetzt diese Schwachstellen kostenlos melden.
Wobei, jetzt müssen wir mal der Ehrlichkeit halber sagen, für diese Schwachstellen hättest du nirgendwo einen Bug Bounty gekriegt. Müssen wir jetzt mal ehrlich sagen.
Richtig, das ist korrekt. Martin hätte an der Stelle aber auch sagen können, ach naja, krieg ich keinen Bug Bounty für. Ich muss hier noch mal einen Bericht zu Ende schreiben von dem letzten bezahlten Pentest. Oder morgen muss ich eh zum Kunden fahren. Oder was auch immer gerade. Ich bin mir sicher, der hat genug zu tun. Und er hätte auch sagen können, okay, dann geordneter Rückzug. Ich hab damit nichts zu tun, ich hab nichts gehört, nichts gesehen. Und halt mir die Augen zu.
Ja das, oder er hätte sagen können, ich hol's einfach aus. Also die unresponsible. Full disclosure.
Einfach zack eine kleine E-Mail schreiben hier. Oder einen kleinen Tweet.
Reit ist ja ethisch fragwürdig. Er hat sich für sie zu sagen, die ethisch anspruchsvolle Variante entschieden.
Ja, und als Dankeschön. Riecht er nach einem Arsch tritt. Wird das jetzt noch in Zweifel gezogen? Oder irgendwie so gut wie möglich klein geredet? Was ich eine sehr interessante Reaktion finde. Aber eben auch, glaube, fürchte ich, eine ist, die vielversprechend ist für so ein Unternehmen. Kurzfristig. Dass sie nämlich die öffentliche Debatte runterhalten können. Und dann quasi nicht so einen hohen Vertrauensschaden nehmen. Wie er ihnen eigentlich dafür gebührt, dass sie so unverantwortlich sogar damit umgehen, dass ihnen jemand sogar noch Schwachstellen in dem System zeigt.
Linus findet uns da schon wieder einig.
Finden wir was, wo wir uns nicht einig sind. netzpolitik.org hat veröffentlicht relativ viele Dokumente zu dem, also ich würde es mal nennen, das Dual-Use-League, veröffentlicht von Daniel Moosbrucker, der ist bei Reporter ohne Grenzen seit einigen Jahren aktiv und mir über diese Rolle, die er da aktiv ausfüllt, auch seit einigen Jahren bekannt. 2014 oder so ging die Debatte eigentlich los, Staatstrojaner als Exportgut oder überhaupt Hacking-Geräte.
Ich glaube, das war ein bisschen dieser arabische Frühling und die haben die Geheimdienstzentrale überrannt und die ganzen Dokumente rausgetragen. Ich habe nicht mehr eine Erinnerung, wie die Firma hieß, aber das war auf jeden Fall eine europäische. Ich finde, das hat es ein bisschen getriggert. Das kann sein, ich weiß es nicht mehr aus dem Kopf. Ich weiß ebenfalls noch, dass da die Dokumente drin waren und dass eine neue Debatte um den Export angestoßen hat. Und dann ist Sigmar Gabriel, der ehemalige Minister und SPD-Vorsitzende, in seiner Rolle damals als Wirtschaftsminister.
Klar, Wirtschaftsexportkontrolle unterliegt wahrscheinlich da gut sein Ministerium, ist hingegangen und hat gesagt, dass diese Überwachungstechnologien, die wir hier aus Deutschland exportieren, da möchte ich bitte dafür sorgen, dass das für ganz Europa irgendwie eine Ordnung, dass wir nur noch ethisch in ethische, also was weiß ich, Saudi-Arabien oder so, dass man irgendwie nur noch nach Saudi-Arabien und so liefert und solche ethisch vertretbaren Demokraturen, aber nicht irgendwie in ethisch nicht vertretbaren Demokraturen. Und da gab es jetzt eine Arbeitsgruppe, die hat sich irgendwie zwei Jahre damit auseinandergesetzt und das wird jetzt irgendwie, hat sogar auch dann eine Studie durchgeführt, durchgeführt, dass die EU-Kommission, die selber festgestellt hat, ja unsere Exportkontrollregeln weisen gravierende Mängel auf.
Und was machen wir jetzt?
Was machen wir jetzt? Ja, möglichst klein reden und möglichst nichts daran ändern. Weil das wäre ja schlecht für diese Unternehmen.
Und vielleicht sollten wir nochmal sagen, also das ist nicht nur Überwachungstechnologien im engeren Sinne, sondern betrifft natürlich auch, was ich jetzt mal Hackingtechnologien nennen würde, also auch welche, die offensiv sind. Also der Begriff Überwachungstechnologien ist fast ein bisschen zu knapp für den Bereich, was das alles betrifft. Oder manchmal ist es auch nur Kombination.
Schade, wie so vollmundige Ankündigungen. Eine sehr vollmundige Ankündigung war ja auch zum Beispiel, dass Maaßen gegangen werden würde. Auch eine sehr vollmundige Ankündigung. Heute konnte man auf Twitter das BMI fragen. Frag den Minister. Die machen ja regelmäßig irgendwie hier...
Das heißt jetzt Heimatministerium, Linus. Hattest du dich beteiligt?
Ich hab mich beteiligt.
Nein, sag mal mit. Ich hab's noch nicht gesehen. In welcher Frage?
Ich hab gefragt, warum ist Maaßen immer noch im Amt? Und dann hab ich keine Antwort bekommen. Und dann hab ich die Frage noch mal gestellt.
Guckst du gerade nach, ob du eine Antwort hast?
Ja, ich hab die Antwort bekommen. Und zwar ist es gesagt, wieso ist Maaßen noch im Amt? Dann kam nix. Und dann hab ich die noch mal gementioned, weil wahrscheinlich, also sie meint, man sollte unter dem Hashtag twittern. Dann hab ich aber offenbar, reichte denen das nicht, dann hab ich die noch mal gementioned. Und darauf hab ich eine Antwort bekommen.
Ich platz gleich jetzt arg. Die ist bestimmt total enttäuschend.
Grafische User Interfaces. Diese Frage beantworten wir regelmäßig. Das können Sie unserem Verlauf leicht entnehmen. Mit anderen Worten...
Haben wir schon woanders beantwortet.
Haben wir schon woanders beantwortet, aber mit anderen Worten auch. Die wird Ihnen wohl oft gestellt. Da scheint es Leute zu geben, die sich dafür interessieren.
Na ja, da gab es noch die kleine Genifke-Anomalie jetzt. Da gab es einen Schlagabtausch mit der ARD. Unglaublich peinlich. Das wird sich jetzt auch immer noch...
Aber die Antwort muss ich dann auch verlesen, die Sie hier noch verlinkt haben. Minister Seehofer hat sich zu dieser Frage bereits geäußert. Eine Entscheidung über die Nachbesetzung des Präsidentenamtes des BfV-Bund. Soll bis Anfang November getroffen werden.
Ja, es sollte ja eigentlich im Oktober sein. Und wenn nicht schon Anfang November, kann man das schon fast so nennen?
Es ist Anfang November quasi, ja.
Na gut, wir wollen ihn mal noch ein paar Tage geben. Ich bin so gespannt auf Horstens Vorschlag.
Der wird irgendwas... Also das Schlimme ist, dass er heute schon weiß, dass der jemanden auswählen wird, wo du sofort sagst, bitte, bitte, bitte Maaßen wieder zurück.
Na gut, aber viel mehr Hardliner als Maaßen wirst du nicht finden.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt, wer vielleicht noch irgendwo...
Also hast du schon einen Namen im Kopf, den du jetzt hier...
Nein, ich hab auch keine Ahnung.
Man kennt das schon, Angst und Schweißausbrüche.
Aber so Seehofer hat bis jetzt immer noch als letztes das Lachen gehabt. Ich bin mal gespannt.
Was macht eigentlich hier der Friedrich, der Ex-Minister?
Ich glaube, der ist wieder zurück auf seinen Bauernhof gegangen, wo der herkam, oder?
Nein, der hat sich doch so radikalisiert auf Twitter.
Warte mal ab, lieber Tim, warte mal ab. Dein Wort in Gottes Gehörgang. Ich bin echt gespannt, ob der... Das wäre so ein Kandidat. Bei uns habt ihr es zuerst erfahren.
Hoffentlich können wir das halten, aber gut. Dann lassen wir mal Maaßen hinter uns, oder?
Ja, leider.
Wir könnten gleich mal über den Seehofer reden, in dem Zusammenhang mit seinem Südkreuz-Debakel, oder?
Ja, das...
Da würde sich eigentlich einschließen.
Ich habe da... Das war ja so ein Thema, das habe ich am Ende nicht mehr verfolgt. Die haben mir dann ihre Studienergebnisse veröffentlicht. Und da kommen dann auch wieder die Statistik-Nurse natürlich raus. Ich muss aber zugeben, ich hatte da keine Zeit. Ich habe einfach keine Zeit gehabt, mir das durchzulesen. Vor allem, wenn bei sowas musst du ja sofort, weißt du ja, das ist ja eine politische Studie. Die wurde ja aus politischen Gründen durchgeführt. Die hat ein politisches Ziel. Mit anderen Worten, die Veröffentlichung muss so passieren, dass sie mit Einklang in diesem politischen Ziel steht.
Das war sogar schon vorher angekündigt. Gibt ja diese berühmte, über die Markus Reuter geschrieben hat, die berühmte parlamentarische Anfrage, wo sich schon vorher angesagt hat, dass dieser Test ein Erfolg wird. Das fanden wir sehr heitert. Naja, der Punkt ist, ich finde so ein bisschen, was mich darin sehr ärgert, ist eigentlich, wie sich das verändert hat über die Jahre. Denn es ist ja längst nicht der erste Biometrietest. Und ich kann mich erinnern, wie wir vor zehn Jahren, da gab es eine Biometriegruppe im Chaos Computer Club zum Beispiel, die hat sich sehr mit der Biometrie auseinandergesetzt. Und wir konnten die Studien, die auch gewissen wissenschaftlichen Ansprüchen entsprochen haben, sehr genau lesen. Ich erinnere an die BIP2L-Studie. Das war damals der größte Test am Flughafen in Frankfurt, wo man Gesichtserkennung und Fingerabdrücke getestet hat. Du konntest sie sehr genau ansehen. Die hatten zum Beispiel, wie man das für eine ordentliche Studie erwartet, eine Kritik drin. Dass sie sagen, wo sind hier die Schwächen und die Stärken der Art, wie wir was messen. Die hatten sogar damals Tests zur Überwindung. Ich glaube, das waren damals 220 Seiten oder so. Also die haben eine ernsthafte, ziemlich wissenschaftliche Studie, an der man auch noch Kritik üben konnte, rausgehauen. Und hier war jetzt anders. Erst haben die gar nichts gesagt. Der Zwischenbericht ist nie veröffentlicht worden. Der Zwischenbericht ist bis heute heim. Und am Ende haben sie eine Studie der Bundespolizei rausgegeben, die natürlich auch sehr, sehr wenig Zahlen enthält. Also wirklich wenig Zahlen. Im Vergleich zu früheren Studien, kannst du nicht wirklich ernst nehmen. Und dann sind die Zahlen halt enorm geschönt. Das kann ich nicht anders sagen. Aus mehreren Gründen. Zum einen haben die natürlich Fotos gemacht von diesen Freiwilligen, die eine hohe Qualität hatten. Also das Ausgangsmaterial ist natürlich hoch. Also von der Qualität. Und das ist überhaupt nicht an die Bevölkerung angepasst. Das heißt, was man üblicherweise machen muss für einen ordentlichen Test, eine Repräsentativität herstellen, war überhaupt nicht gegeben. So haben die die nicht ausgesucht. Und das müsste man natürlich eigentlich tun.
Könnten die nicht behaupten, na ja, mit dem neuen Personalausweisgesetz haben wir doch dann eh bald die vollständige Biometriedatenbank in Deutschland?
Aber als der gestartet wurde, war nicht klar, dass es flächendeckend sein soll. Also die sind ja nicht angetreten zu sagen, wir wollen hier ein Bevölkerungsüberwachungsprogramm testen, sondern sie wollten ja sozusagen Verhandlungsbilder nehmen. Erst später hat dann Demisier sozusagen zur Veröffentlichung der ersten Zwischenergebnisse dann gesagt, wir könnten uns das flächendeckend vorstellen. Also die haben ja am Anfang nicht so getan, als wenn sie jetzt hier das coole Überwachungsinstrument ausrollen, sondern sie wollten ja eigentlich nach bestimmten Leuten fahren, nämlich aus besonderen, sozusagen gefährlichen Menschen. So war das ja eigentlich mal geplant.
Und mit diesen, mit diesen trotzdem, also quasi auf jeden Fall mit dem bestmöglichen Bildmaterial?
Nee, aber das kommt noch besser. Das war der erste Teil. Es gibt einen zweiten Teil. Als Demisija sich hinstellt, ich war damals auch da am Bahnhof und hab mir das angehört. Er war ja live bei seinem Vorzeigeprojekt. Da hat er ja angekündigt, ja, wir müssen den Test verlängern. Und dafür werden wir die Bilder etwas realitätsnah machen. Denn die Kritik daran, dass diese ursprünglichen Bilder, die sie aufgenommen haben, natürlich so eine hohe Qualität haben, die hätte er damit quasi aufgenommen. In Wahrheit, und das kann man natürlich jetzt in der Studie nachlesen, haben die Bilder von den Kameras selbst genommen. Also, das heißt, die, die schon in der Perspektive, zum Beispiel auf der Rolltreppe sind, das heißt, die haben nicht etwa, zu sagen, schlechtere Fotos genommen oder realitätsnähere, sondern sie haben die genommen, die von dem System selbst gemacht wurde an der selben Stelle. Das ist ja wohl die absolute Frechheit.
Also, das ist bemerkenswert.
Und dann haben sie natürlich auch noch die Zahlen, die sie rausgeben, insofern geschönt, dass sie ein, zu sagen, imaginäres Gesamtsystem aus den drei getesteten bilden. Das heißt, sie nehmen die Zahlen zusammen. Das heißt, die Endergebnisse, die sie da rausgegeben haben, zum Beispiel diese 80%, die sind von keinem dieser System erreicht worden, sondern sind zusammengenommen, als wenn man nun immer drei Systeme da laufen lassen würde.
Eins von den dreien hat schon irgendwie immer mal...
Und zusammen haben sie diesen Wert ergeben. Aber es sind auch viele Einzelheiten.
Die Frage ist, also 80% ist das eine gute Quote? Nein, die ist doch total schlecht.
Sie ist natürlich auch schlecht, weil man immer die Fehlernahme...
Das heißt ja, das Ding piept am Laufenden Band und ab und zu wäre dann auch tatsächlich mal ein Gesicht erkannt worden.
Ja, das und vor allen Dingen die, die gesucht werden, werden eben teilweise nicht erkannt. Aber sie hatten auch... Sie kamen auch sehr auf die... wo die Kamera war an. Sie hatten auch Probleme mit Gegenlicht bei bestimmten Kameras, zum Beispiel am Ausgang des Bahnhofs. Also da waren die Ergebnisse noch viel schlechter. Also die waren ja nicht immer so gut. Oh man, ey. Aber das geht übrigens weiter. Da gibt es eine zweite Phase.
Das Problem ist natürlich... Sie sagen jetzt, das ist gut. Oder die sind ja begeistert von...
Seowati sagt, dass die Ergebnisse zeigen würden, dass das einsatzbereit sei. Und er hat sich auch nicht distanziert von dem flächendeckenden Demisier-Aussagen.
Mein Problem wäre, dass es früher oder später halt flächend... Weil es irgendwann so gut sein wird. Wir werden uns ja nicht darauf ausruhen können, dass, wenn die es jetzt 2018 nicht hinkriegen, dass quasi mit verbesserten Kameras, verbesserter Technologie, dass vielleicht 2025 funktioniert.
Nee, und ich halte das auch nicht für ein gutes Argument. Also sich nur auf die technische Unfähigkeit zurückzuziehen. Natürlich wirst du weiterhin Fehlalarm haben. Das wird dir immer passieren. Und das kann natürlich sehr belastend sein, je nachdem, wo das eingebaut ist. Aber du wirst sicherlich eine Verbesserung haben über die Zeit, auch wegen der Optiken und letztlich wegen der Software. Das eigentliche Problem ist aber sehr viel größer. Sie müssen ja ein Gesetz schaffen, weil du ja jeden Menschen aufnimmst, um sozusagen gegen zu checken. Und dafür brauchen sie ein Gesetz. Du könntest es ja nicht flächendeckend machen, ohne dass du dafür eine gesetzliche Grundlage hast, weil das ist eine anlasslose Körperdatenerfassung von jedem, der da vorbeigeht. Und deswegen haben sich ja auch etwa der Deutsche Anwaltverein und so also auch juristisch sehr viel Kritik daran.
Und deswegen wollen sie das jetzt als großen Erfolg verkaufen, damit die Leute, wenn dann das die entsprechende Gesetzesänderung dazu kommt, die Leute sagen können, ah ja, das war schön damals am Südkreuz, wo wir uns alle erkannt haben.
Es ist halt, ich fände, vielleicht bin ich da auch zu idealistisch, ich hätte mir einfach mehr Ehrlichkeit erwartet und auch mehr Genauigkeit bei den Daten, die die da rausgeben. Ich fand das sehr enttäuschend, wie lange die gemauert haben. Ehe wir überhaupt mal Zahlen hatten, die man in Ruhe lesen konnte. Und dass sie eigentlich auf die juristische Kritik, die sich ja an dieser anlasslosen Biometrieerfassung hochzieht, einfach ignoriert haben. Seehofer hat eh nicht viel dazu gesagt. Das war ja eher sein Vorgängervorzeigeprojekt.
Manchmal, wenn der Seehofer nichts sagt, kann man ja vielleicht auch manchmal froh sein.
Warst du schon mal in einer Pressekonferenz von dem angeguckt? Ich finde, das ist kaum zum aushalten. Das ist schwierig. Ich habe mir die angesehen zu ADEK, dieser Agentur für disruptive...
Innovationen im Cyberraum, oder was?
Das war ja unglaublich. Er hatte nur Glück, dass er so nah an Kennenetz dran war und dass dann die Journalisten eigentlich wenig zu dieser ADEK Agentur gefragt haben. Das ist ein peinlicher Auftritt. Aber auch die Maaßen-Pressekonferenz, die habe ich noch im Stream geguckt, unglaublich. Das Tittenminister ist also einer der Spitzenämter dieser Bundesrepublik. Hätte ich für unglaublich. Der Typ ist wirklich nicht mehr so der Zelektion.
Hatten wir doch auch vor zwei Folgen oder so eingespielt, oder drei Folgen, wie er nach dem PC-Wahl noch mal gefragt wurde und dann so... Also ich war es nicht schuld.
Ich glaube, das hatte der gar nicht mit dir halt, oder? Das hat der gar nicht verstanden.
Na ja, ich hoffe, dass er das deswegen meinte, weil er wusste, dass er da noch nicht Innenminister war. Na ja, vielleicht. Das wäre so die charakterstärkste, humorvolle Interpretation eines solchen Spruchs. Aber der eine Satz, der dir nie über den Mund gehen darf als Minister ist, ich war nicht schuld.
Na ja, oder meine Antwort würde die Bevölkerung verunsichern.
Ja, der darf dir auch nicht überdenken.
Okay, aber wollen wir mal Südkreuz abhaken, oder? Also wer das nachlesen will, gab ja eine ganze Reihe Berichterstattung und so.
Pressemitteilungen vom CCC.
Das auch, genau. Und Starbucks hat auch ein bisschen im Radio erklärt.
Wunderbar. Wollen wir uns noch ein bisschen mit Hass im Netz auseinandersetzen?
Oh ja, Hass, ich hab ganz viel Hass, wenn ich im Netz bin, du auch. Ist übrigens, also Chaosradio Hass im Netz ist ja heute auch noch ab.
War das nicht schon?
Ne, heute, heute Abend.
Okay, dann hab ich das falsch auf dem Schirm gehabt.
Vielleicht machst du Zeitreisen, Linus?
Kann auch sein.
No, naja noch.
Noch nicht.
Weiß man nicht, wie das mal wird.
Aber wenn die das ändern wollen, werde ich es verhindern.
Ich hab da immer so Probleme mit den Paradoxen, die da zwangsläufig entstehen. Aber gut. Hast du im Netz, du meinst bestimmt Sigi Maurer?
Ja, das ist ein Fall, über den haben wir, der ist gar nicht mehr so aktuell, aber über den haben wir nicht gesprochen, weil verschiedene Themen und Gäste bei uns zu Gast waren. Eine Politikerin aus Österreich, der Grünen, wird von einem Mann über Facebook sehr sehr unfletig in Direktnachrichten.
Und auch wirklich blöde.
Also doof und geschmacklos und irgendwie ekelig. Also wirklich einfach peinlich. Nur peinlich.
Aber daran sind sich glaube ich auch erstmal alle einig, dass das wirklich geschmacklos war.
Ich glaube, wir werden wahrscheinlich Ärger kriegen, dass wir es nur als geschmacklos bezeichnen. Das war einfach pervers. Ich kann viele Adjektive, wollen wir?
Wir sind uns einig.
Was macht sie? Nehmt diese Nachricht, macht einen Screenshot und veröffentlicht die. So weit, so gut fand ich in dem Falle denke ich auch wirklich angemessen, weil das auch, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass diese Nachrichten zu schreiben nicht auch ein Straftatbestand war.
In Österreich ist ja die Gesetzeslage ein bisschen anders. Man kann jemanden sehr viel schwieriger beleidigen, wenn man ihm nicht direkt gegenüber steht. Also virtuell beleidigen sozusagen. Anders als in Deutschland. Aber wir sind ja nicht Juristen, wir müssen ja sozusagen ihn zu nicht bewerten, ob das schon eine Straftat gewesen wäre. Der Punkt ist ja, dass sie für was anderes verurteilt wurde.
Sie wurde dann dafür verurteilt, diese Nachricht veröffentlicht zu haben.
Und seinen Ruf geschädigt zu haben.
Und seinen Ruf geschädigt zu haben. Das ist echt scharf, weil das Krasse ist, dass ich der Argumentation des Richters sogar teilweise... Also ich kann zumindest folgen. Ich würde die Argumentation nicht teilen. Aber die Argumentation lautet ungefähr so, na ja, der Typ sitzt hier vor Gericht und sagt, sein Facebook-Account wäre gehackt gewesen.
Oder jemand anders kann ihn mitbenutzen.
Oder kann ihn mitbenutzen oder so.
Ist ja quasi öffentlich, steht da rum.
Und deswegen hätte sie ihn vorher fragen müssen, ob er das war. Wenn er dann Ja gesagt hätte, dann wäre alles gut gewesen. Aber in dem Fall nein. Ich glaube, ihre humorvolle Reaktion darauf war ja dann irgendwie so, dass sie bei den nächsten, jetzt werden sie immer von irgendwelchen Leuten, die ihr natürlich jetzt die ganze Zeit noch den Tod wünschen und alles Mögliche androhen, dass sie den dann immer antwortet.
Bitte nennen sie mir doch ihre Identität.
Können sie bitte kurz bestätigen, dass sie mir diese Nachricht geschickt haben?
Mich hat was anderes daran fasziniert, weswegen wir jetzt auch noch mal kurz darüber sprechen, obwohl es schon ein bisschen her ist. Das Interessante ist ja, dass sie nicht nur diese Form von Gegenwehr und auch ein bisschen Kommentierung sozusagen wird, sondern sie hat ja quasi so eine Art Initiative, um sich auch ein bisschen strategisch dagegen zu wehren. Und dabei, ich fand faszinierend, wie viele Leute sich beteiligt haben, in wie kurzer Zeit. Und das sieht wie so eine Art, als wenn manchmal Leute darauf warten, dass sie da so ein bisschen Engagement in Form von Geld auch hinterstecken können. Das hat mich fasziniert.
Also verurteilt wurde sie zu einer Zahlung von 7.000 Euro und ein bisschen mehr. 7.000 Pakte zerquetschte. Und sie hat dann einen Fonds irgendwie ausgerufen auf so einer Crowdfunding-Plattform und hat gesagt, hier kommt das Geld rein für Menschen, denen es genauso geht wie mir. Genau. Oder die solchen Dingen ausgesetzt werden und sich zu wehr setzen wollen. Und da kann jetzt Geld eingezahlt werden. Und das Ding war irgendwie ruckizucki auf irgendwie weit über 100.000 Euro. Und ich weiß gar nicht, bei wie viel das jetzt ist.
Und sie macht es nicht nur für sich, sondern...
Nein, nein, genau. Der wird dann eben verwaltet. Da kann man sich dann mit seinen Fällen dran wenden.
Ich finde es so schön, wenn Leute was wirklich uneinehmend und blödet so angenehm drehen können. Also natürlich hat sie auch eine Menge abgekriegt, was bestimmt auch nicht leicht ist. Aber indem man daraus irgendwie was Positives, Aktivistisches dreht, ich fass es faszinierend. Und das ist glaube ich auch der Grund, warum sich dann so viele beteiligen. Weil die das auch sehen oder weil die auch... Also ich glaube, das triggert die Gerechtigkeit zu viel von Leuten.
Und ich glaube schon, dass das, auch wenn es da draußen im Internet teilweise anders aussieht, dass das eigentlich schon für den überwiegenden Teil der Menschen ein Wunsch und Ziel ist, dass man gesittet miteinander umgeht und dass irgendwie Menschen nicht so behandelt werden. Egal, was für Menschen und egal von wem.
Man kriegt ja immer so ein bisschen den Glauben an die Menschheit oft wieder bei sowas. Also, das ging mir auch so ein bisschen bei Constanze Fall vom europäischen Menschenrechtsrechtshof zu. Also wenn du dann siehst, dass das irgendwie außerhalb Europa, da Leute kleine Summen spenden, dann ist das ein unglaublicher Motivationsschub. Oder das könnte man auch für den Schrebsfall sagen. Wo einfach Leute, ganz viele kleine Summen, sich beteiligen. Und das war bei Sigi Maurer, finde ich, sehr schön. Und ich fand das auch sehr glaubwürdig, dass sie das selber so nicht erwartet hätte, dass das so viele sind.
Aber umso, das sind irgendwie die nötigen schönen Zeichen der Zivilgesellschaft.
Wo wir immer so zynisch sind hier im Podcast. Da könnten wir eigentlich kurz über die Massenüberwachung reden, wo wir gerade den Fall vom europäischen Menschenrechtsgericht kurz angerissen haben. Denn heute kam noch eine gute Nachricht nach aus Schweden. Denn wir erinnern uns ja, im September gab es das Urteil zum britischen GCHQ, wo wir eigentlich reden wollten. Aber dann haben wir das irgendwie nicht hinbekommen. Aber egal, es war ein positiver Urteil nach langen Jahren. Nämlich gegen die britische Massenüberwachung der Geheimdienste. Leider hatte es kurz vorher, nämlich im Juni, einen anderen Fall in Europa gegeben. Nämlich die schwedische Gesetzgebung, die gescheitert waren in Straßburg beim europäischen Menschenrechtsgerichtshof. Die haben sich sozusagen heute mit einer Pressemitteilung an die Öffentlichkeit gewandt und haben mir gesagt, wir ziehen das im zweiten Versuch nochmal durch. Du kannst nämlich, wenn du so einen Fall hast und nicht die große Kammer hat entschieden, also wenn du scheiterst, dann hast du nochmal eine Frist und kannst sagen, ich möchte der großen Kammer vorlegen, wenn du gute Argumente hast. Und dazwischen, durch der Fall von den Briten gefallen war und auch innerhalb von deren Frist war, haben die selber nochmal eine Beschwerde gelegen, sozusagen den schwedischen Fall nochmal vor. Und ich finde ihn deshalb spannend, weil sie sehr interessante Fragen aufwerfen. Nämlich nicht nur zur Massenüberwachung selbst, denn dazu gab es ja schon ein Urteil, sondern vor allen Dingen zur Aufsicht. Also wie ist denn das Minimum für eine unabhängige juristische Aufsicht? Das finde ich eine sehr wichtige Frage. Was sind überhaupt minimale notwendige Sicherheitsvorkehrungen gegen Missbrauch und gegen Willkür? Find ich auch eine entscheidende Frage. Denn das ist ja auch gerade so, was bei dem anderen Urteil gegen die Briten eine Rolle gespielt hat. Dass man eben, wenn man so Metadaten zusammen glaubt, dass man da auch ordentliche Grenzen haben muss für Missbrauchsprävention.
Wie wir es kürzlich in Frankreich gesehen haben, wo der Agent die Sachen im Darknet verkauft hat für irgendwie 100 bis 300 Euro.
Wir haben jetzt wieder so einen Fall, also die Briten bei Privates International, die illegalerweise abgehört haben, also gegen ihre eigenen Regeln. Und das wäre ja eine Form von Missbrauchsprävention. Das müssen wir nicht genauer ausführen, aber ich finde interessant, welche spannenden Fragen die vorlegen und man kann nur hoffen, dass die damit noch mal durchdringen. Das wäre noch mal wichtig. Sowas gibt es mir auch, das ist so ähnlich wie bei Sigi Maurer, selbst wenn du manchmal Jahre wartest und bei dem GCHQ-Fall wartest, mehr als 4 Jahre, du kannst halt sehen, dass es rechtsstaatliche Elemente gibt, hier die Menschenrechtskonvention. Und wenn du nur langen Atem genug hast, kannst du das durchziehen. Du kannst das einfach zumindest versuchen. Ich halte dich für einen hohen Wert.
Absolut.
Irgendwoher muss man ja die Motivation auch nehmen.
Schade, dass es so viele Jahre dauert und dass es am laufenden Band wieder der Fall wird. Ich denke, das sieht ja bei den NGOs nicht nur im netzpolitischen Bereich, sondern auch in anderen Bereichen auch so. Es ist ja nicht nur diese Massenüberwachung, die uns regelmäßig kümmert, aber es geht ja auch um alle möglichen komischen Gesetzgebungen, gegen die sich Organisationen zu wehrsetzen.
Außerdem haben wir gerade 70 Jahre Menschenrechte, woran ich mal erinnern möchte. Sie hat gerade eine schöne große Kampagne.
Überhaupt oder in Europa?
Allgemeine Erklärung der Menschenrechte. Also nicht die Menschenrechtskonvention. Die ist von 51 ratifiziert. Also die allgemeine Erklärung der Menschenrechte ist etwas älter. Man muss daran manchmal erinnern. Ich glaube, vielleicht ist das vermessen, aber mein Eindruck ist oft, dass diese grundsätzlichen menschenrechtlichen Fragen bei der Bewachung für viele andere der Menschenrechte eine Voraussetzung sind. Weil wenn du was nicht überwachungsfrei tun kannst, je nachdem, wie hoch dein Repressionslevel ist, dann kannst du viele andere Menschenrechte auch nicht ausüben. Also das stimmt bestimmt nicht immer, weil manchmal ist das Reziprog oder so. Aber ich halte das für viele andere Menschenrechte und deren praktische Ausübung für absolut elementar. Wir wollen hoffen, Schocker oder Linus?
Wir haben noch ein kleines Thema.
Haben wir noch? Was haben wir denn? Ach so, die Tracker-Studie?
Nee, YouTuber aller Länder vereint euch.
Ach ja, die Gewerkschaft der YouTuber.
Das finde ich, ich finde das ja, also das ist so ein Ding, das, ja, da siehst du mal was.
Na ja, guck, wir müssen mal zusammenfassen. Also das eine ist, Gewerkschaft ist nicht wirklich ein Begriff, der trifft, aber sie wollten sich zusammen tun.
Union nennen sie sich, oder? YouTubers Union.
Naja, ich glaube im Deutschen versteht man unter Gewerkschaft irgendwie was anderes, oder? Aber wir wissen ja, okay, eine Interessenvertretung quasi, wenn man das mal so nennen würden, oder? Und sie wollen ihr Recht auf Gewinn durchsetzen. Sie wollen ihr Einkommen bei YouTube behalten. Nein, sie haben Forderungen, die wir albern finden, aber sie haben auch welche, die wir ganz gut finden, oder?
Ich kann das so schwer sagen. Das sind jetzt also Menschen, die irgendwie über YouTube Geld verdienen.
Also auch teilweise richtig ihr Einkommen, also nicht nur nebenbei.
Es gibt ja ein paar YouTuber, von denen sagt man, dass sie sehr viel Geld verdienen.
Ein paar Zehntausende?
Mag ja sein, dann gibt es irgendwie... Irgendwie haben die da aber auch Konflikte, weil wir erinnern uns nicht so lange her, dass da die eine Person auf dem YouTube-Headquarter da irgendwie auch rumgeballert hatte. Also dieser Konflikt schweht da schon länger. Die Arbeiterklasse begehrt auf. Und die beschweren sich über ihre Bedingungen da.
Und vor allen Dingen auch, wenn die geändert werden, ohne dass sie da viel machen können.
Genau, die können nichts machen, natürlich.
Oder Willkür generell?
Willkür, also das rechtliche Verhältnis, was die gegenüber YouTube haben, ist ja mehr oder weniger, dass YouTube sagt, bis auf weiteres zahlen wir dir so und so viel pro Klick. Oder wir zahlen dir eine Beteiligung an den Werbekosten. Und dies folgen dies so und so viel. Und wenn YouTube sich das anders überlegt und daran etwas ändert, dann wird das per E-Mail mitgeteilt.
Was schonmal erst mal nett ist, wissen sie vielleicht nicht.
Aber ja. Man lacht da jetzt so drüber, aber im Prinzip ist das eine absolute prekäre Situation, in der die sich da befinden. Eine absolute Abhängigkeit. Und das hast du eigentlich nirgendwo sonst. In den Bereichen, in denen wir Verhältnisse geklärt haben zwischen Arbeitern oder Arbeiterinnen oder Dienstleistern, die verschiedenen Institutionen, verschiedene Vertragsverhältnisse und warum zum Beispiel auch in Deutschland immer sehr davor gewarnt wird, quasi so vor der Scheinselbständigkeit. Jetzt sind die natürlich, die können nichts anderes sein als selbständige YouTube-Fuzzies, weil wenn die schlechtere Videos machen und diese Videos weniger geklickt werden, dann kann jetzt nicht YouTube Schlechtwettergeld zahlen oder so. Aber die haben sich da jetzt in diese Plattform begeben und diese Plattform...
Bringt sie um. Und diese Plattform macht natürlich je nach Ihren Interessen und nicht unbedingt... Naja, ich beobachte ja eine gewisse Diversifizierung. Also mir ist bei YouTube-Kanälen, die ich jetzt selber gerne gucke, gibt es ja so einige... Ich YouTube nicht, wie ihr sicherlich wisst, aber ich gucke viele. Ich merke natürlich in der Diversifizierung, es gibt immer mehr, die zum Beispiel Patreon mitnutzen. Oder die zumindest einen zweiten Kanal haben. Oft ist es Facebook. Also seit Facebook Video ja doch relativ groß geworden ist. Aber es gibt eben einen großen Teil, was es nicht hat. Also die wirklich einen Standbein haben. Und nicht drei. Oder sogar fünf. Also der Zuspitzen auf diese eine Streaming- und Videoplattform, die hat halt, glaube ich, die Macht verstärkt. Und die zweite ist diese Nichtlösen von Konflikten. Also wenn automatisiert wird, runtergenommen wird. Das liest die auch dauernd. Kannst du im englischsprachigen Raum noch viel mehr finden als bei uns. Dass du niemanden erreichst, der dir deinen Konflikt löst. Und wenn das nur mal deine Miete ist. Die Frage ist, wird das was bringen, wenn die sich jetzt in einer Union...
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall ganz interessant, dass wir irgendwie dieses Internet erfinden. Dann irgendwann eine Streaming-Plattform da sich bildet, um ein bisschen Videos zu gucken. Von Google gekauft wird. Plötzlich langsam Monetarisierungsmöglichkeiten bietet. Ich weiß nicht, seit wann YouTube das hat. Dann hast du da... Diese Monetarisierung kommt ja aus der Werbung, die die da schalten. Also, die ich ja auch schon wieder irgendwie nervlich finde.
Und die hat sich gerade verändert, also vor allen Dingen verlängert.
Die wird jetzt länger, weil jetzt YouTube irgendwie kürzlich eingeführt hat. Man kann eben da auch bezahlen, dann ist es werbefrei. Und gleichzeitig YouTube offenbar jetzt wahrscheinlich langsam mal... Ich kenne tatsächlich den finanziellen Zustand des Unternehmens nicht. Ich würde vermuten, dass sie jetzt mal langsam eine Perspektive haben, damit Geld zu verdienen. Ich glaube nicht, dass das in den Jahren davor unbedingt der Fall war. Weil dieses YouTube da irgendwie laufen zu lassen, die Serverfarm wird schon den ein oder andere Schluck aus der Stromflasche nehmen. Das Ding ist ein teures Teil.
Ja, das ist vor allen Dingen im Wesentlichen konkurrenzlos. Es gibt natürlich andere Plattformen, aber die sind, verglichen einfach mit dem Traffic, viel, viel kleiner.
Und dann bildet sich auf einmal, die merken natürlich auch Menschen so, hey, wir sind doch die, die hier den ganzen Inhalt liefern. Und wir pudern hier von morgens bis abends in dieses YouTube rein. Und ohne uns wäre YouTube nichts. Und dann denken eben die YouTuber aller Länder, alles steht hier still, wenn mein Webcam das will. Und dann versuchen sie jetzt irgendwie ihre Kraft da irgendwie zu bündeln.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin da irgendwie immer zerrissen. Ich kann das zum einen verstehen, aber zum anderen natürlich auch nicht. Also ich werde da glaube ich auch mit mir selber nie einig. Ich kann nicht verstehen, dass sie das extrem ungerecht finden. Und sie sind natürlich auch diejenigen, die die Inhalte schaffen. Und eine Plattform ist halt nichts ohne diese ganzen kleinen und großen YouTube-Stars und das viele Liebevolle, was Leute in ihre Kanäle stecken. Also die, die ich gucke, ich mag die auf eine Weise. Aber ich habe natürlich auf der anderen Seite meine andere. Ich weiß, wenn du dich in dieser Weise abhängig machst, bist du irgendwie auch selber schuld. Die Bedingungen dieser Plattform sind bekannt. Du kannst dich damit auseinandersetzen. Also ich habe da immer zwei Seiten in mir. Ich verstehe auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite sage ich, wer sozusagen, wo dein einziges Standbein ist, bist du selber schuld. Und ich glaube, irgendwo dazwischen ist wahrscheinlich die Wahrheit.
Also ich tue mich schwer den... Also natürlich ist mein erster Gedanke, als ich das gelesen habe, war auch so, Alter, so, das hätte ich dir vorher sagen können. Aber andererseits weißt du nicht, ob die sich jemals eine Existenz hätten aufbauen können mit irgendwie Webcam-Videos von ihrem eigenen Server.
Natürlich, wahrscheinlich eher nicht. Die Antwort ist wahrscheinlich in den meisten Fällen nie.
Und genauso musst du dir vielleicht überlegen, wie jetzt andere Verhältnisse zwischen Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmern sind oder Arbeitgeber und denen, die sie ausnutzen und die sie noch nicht mal als Arbeitnehmer da haben. Da gibt es natürlich auch eben Ansprüche und mit denen solidarisiere ich mich auf jeden Fall eher mit denen, die jetzt da YouTube-Videos machen und dafür irgendwie mehr Geld von Google haben wollen, als Google, die im Prinzip da halt so eine Serverfarm laufen haben. Die Forderung, sie wollen, dass sie alle Geld bekommen sollen, auch kleinere Kanäle. Es gibt wohl offenbar eine Schwelle, dass kleine Kanäle eben gar nichts bekommen haben. Die Demoletarisierung soll stoppen. Die Werbung sollen also auf einer geraden Skala weiterlaufen. Also es gibt quasi, dass sie da irgendwie interferieren oder so was. Bots sollen raus. Es soll oder verifizierte Partner geben, die irgendwie gucken, bevor ein Kanal rausgenommen wird, weil das eben teilweise heute automatisch passiert. Und das kann natürlich dann eben schlecht sein. Siehe Alex Jones. Also man soll eine, irgendwie, dass sie überhaupt mal eine Kommunikationsmöglichkeit da haben.
Na auch, dass sie überhaupt mal die Kriterien nennen, nach denen, also sozusagen da vorgegangen wird, ist ja eigentlich eine relativ große Forderung. Sie ist quasi revolutionär.
Clarify the rules, bring clear rules with clear examples, what is okay and what is a no-no.
Also das ist nicht, ich finde das deutlich mehr als Transparenz, denn damit committest du dich ja auch zu deinen eigenen Regeln.
Ja, wie Twitter.
Naja, dass die teilweise sagen, du kannst das falsch finden, aber dass sie das aufgeschrieben haben, bei bestimmten Plattformen, finde ich erst mal besser, als wenn es keine Form von...
Völlig klar, natürlich. Das muss niedergeschrieben stehen. Regeln müssen niedergeschrieben stehen. Wenn sie das nicht sind, dann hast du Willkür. In die eine oder in die andere Richtung. Und dann hast du auf jeden Fall einen unfairen Prozess. Und Beispiele dafür, wo dieser Prozess im einen Fall anders gelaufen ist als im anderen. Und dann hast du auf einmal eine Union auf der Barrikade stehen.
Das ist die erste internationale Gewerkschaft, die wir je haben werden. Weißt du, über die wir uns jetzt so halblustig lassen.
Genau, das wird nochmal die internationale.
Wir könnten zweistimmig internationale anstimmen, Linus.
Man soll für die Views bezahlen. Sie wollen gleiche Behandlung für alle. Und die Bezahlung wird angemessen an dem gelieferten Wert. Das ist mir nicht ganz klar.
An dem gelieferten Wert?
Ja, das Werbegeld soll über alle YouTuber ausgeschüttet werden. Gemessen an, wie viel Publikum die haben. Nicht gemessen daran, ob da Werbung neben dem Content ist.
Ah, verstehe. Das ist ja Sozialismus. Was soll das denn?
Ich sag dir, das ist die Internationale.
So ein bisschen meine Sympathie überwiegt etwas, ehrlich gesagt, gegenüber meinem Toad You So Erstgedanken. Den hatte ich nämlich auch.
Als nächstes gründet sich hier die Pottlove Internationale.
Du bist ja nicht recht ansehend. Wieso hast du eigentlich nie außer Sprechen auch mal Video laufen?
Weil du mich das nicht machen lässt.
Ach so, ich will sozusagen der Grund, warum... Ich könnte doch eine sexy Maske tragen.
Ja, aber Union findet halt nicht so viele Leute sexy, Tim. Diese Mütze, die du da trägst, da musst du dich nicht wundern.
Na gut, wir werden jedenfalls, ich sag mal so, diese Union im Auge behalten. Dann könnte vielleicht der Beginn der Weltrevolution sein, von dem wir das jetzt nicht vermuten.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall solidarisch und schaue mir das an.
Ich glaube, es liegt auch ein bisschen daran, dass ich einfach bestimmte YouTuber sehr mag, in denen ich einfach jahrelang folge teilweise. Weiß ich auch nicht, also ich glaube, die Sympathie ist eher bei denen, die den Content machen. Ah, da sind wir uns schon wieder einig, Linus.
Genau, die Sympathie ist bei denen, die den Content machen, also bei uns. Und dann kündigen wir noch einmal kurz etwas an, und zwar die Termine. Am 18. November veranstaltet der Arbeitskreis Menschenrechte Digital Hamburg von MST International ein Kinoabend und da werden zwei Filme gezeigt. Einmal The Cleaners, das ist dieser Film über sehr sehenswert. Die Menschen, die bei Facebook aufräumen müssen, also auf der Seite Inhalte und Inside WikiLeaks, diese WikiLeaks-Doku von Laura Poytras, die nicht kontrovers war, aber sicherlich auch einen sehr interessanten Einblick bietet in die Machenschaften der äquatorianischen Botschaft.
Das ist ja mal interessant. Gehen wir mal hin, oder?
Beides findet statt, genau, in Hamburg im Kino 3001. Links dazu findest du in den Show Notes. Sagt er...
Eintritt ist Überraschung.
So, und damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung. Lieber Tim, ich danke dir.
Oh Linus, war mir eine Freude.
Ich hoffe, du hast es auch gut zurück geschafft aus Wien.
Ja, danke, du auch.
Ich musste ja nicht morgens um 7 zurückfliegen, um noch ein Unionsspiel zu sehen.
Ich schon.
Jeder ist seines eigenen Gluckes Schmied. Wir sind am Ende der Sendung, danken euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit und hören uns beim nächsten Mal.
Ciao.